news daily from science missions such as  rate of in vitro fertilization is around  thirty to thirty-five percent due to the  chromosomal abnormalities in fifty to  eighty percent of embryos in a study  using 117 human zygotes originating from  19 couples scientists demonstrate in the  journal Nature communications a subset  of 12 genes that are activated within  the first 30 hours of development at the  cell one stage these genes can be used  to predict whether an embryo is  chromosomally normal or abnormal at the  early stage of human development next  malaria parasites is a complex process  to enter human red blood cells and  survive the researchers found that  protein kinase G plays a central role in  various pathways that allow the parasite  to survive in the blood pkg  phosphorylates various proteins and  blocking pkg prevents this  phosphorylation and survival of parasite  for more news visit as a at www science  mission calm or science mission facebook  page thanks for watching